so as many of you know because you've
emailed me about it I was on Fox News
yesterday and I had a discussion with
Kyle kolinsky of secular talk before and
I was basically talking to him about
whether we think that it's worth doing
Fox News knowing that it gets so stacked
against the left discussed knowing that
it's mostly an echo chamber of
unthinking reflexive conservative I hate
to even call it thought they're sort of
non thought because you might get
somebody who's willing to hear another
point of view or do you just say no and
Kyle's view was any opportunity to show
up and actually get your voice heard in
front of people who disagree is an
opportunity to change someone's mind and
therefore it's worth it so I decided to
do it I was invited
Leland Vitter was the host bitter I
think is his last name
I was opposite Philadelphia radio host
Dom Giordano of course in an attempt to
I guess not give me the credit that
could have been given to me they called
me Boston radio host opposite Dom as
Philadelphia radio host of course
implying that I guess host local radio
in Boston and don't have a syndicated
show on I think it's a swipe at new
media nobody's on you they don't want to
recognize their platform they also
didn't make any mention of the online
platform that's also true the topic was
the Trump Putin summit mostly they also
said right before going on that it was
going to be a four-minute segment unless
it went really well the idea of having
two guests on for a four-minute segment
is clearly what you do when you don't
actually want to explore ideas and depth
which they don't and they also said to
me before going on engage with each
other which we know what that means it
means start arguing with each other so
my strategy going in and I'm gonna play
the clip for you is I knew that as soon
as I would try to explain a point given
that there were four minutes allocated
for an interview with two guests they
would try to interrupt me so my goal was
stick to what I want to say if
interrupted go back to what I want to
say and see what I can do and you will
immediately realize that whenever I
actually started to make a point I would
immediately be interrupted and given
some kind of different question to
answer and it was a completely expected
tactic there was also the attempt made
by the
host to take on my views sort of in
addition to this dom guy so it ended up
being not surprisingly me against the
conservative guest and the host Leland
Vitter
but I I expected this stuff right I went
in knowing that last thing people
pointed out that I look extraordinarily
white compared to the other two I don't
know if this is done deliberately but
I've noticed that many times the leftist
guest is poorly lit and the second I
walked into the studio where I I just
sit in a dark room to do this and join
them via satellite I immediately saw
compared to our lighting here which
makes me look sort of like a human being
it's too white I'm there I don't know if
it's deliberate or not but this is not
going to look right and not surprisingly
I didn't look orange which is a good
thing but I definitely looked like a
vampire so let's get into the first part
of this interview on Fox News and let's
talk about this with Dom Giordano David
Pakman radio hosts in their respective
cities Philadelphia and Boston as they
are gentlemen nice to see ya Dom what's
striking is when you listen to the
president's advisors whether it be John
Huntsman national security adviser
Bolden or others they are far harsher in
their rhetoric than the president what
do you make of it that's true Leland and
I wish the president were a harsher in
his but the actions of President Trump
what his administration is actually
doing we put more sanctions on Putin
we've kicked out more of the delegates
from the Soviet informant from Russia so
his actions have been firm in this
manner and I think it's way overblown
that he's going to give away the store
President Trump is not going to do that
in any kind of negotiation
I wish the rhetoric though we're more
direct toward putin that's where I
usually am David it brings up an
interesting point it is the less problem
with President Trump among many that
they have the way he goes about foreign
policy or actually the substance of it
because his David points out Dom points
out he's been pretty tough on Putin much
tougher than Obama in many ways by
selling youthful weapons to the
Ukrainians yeah I think that the problem
really is the easily manipulable reality
of Donald Trump and I think if we want
to sort of a preview of what we could
expect with Putin we look at what
happened with Kim jong-un and where
Donald Trump claimed victory on the
basis of the exact same vague promises
that we've gotten from North Korea
before tweeted on the way back that the
nuclear threat is over and we just
learned that in that vein the president
just tweeted even this morning he said
wait a second he said it's been nine
months there hasn't been a nuclear test
and there hasn't been a missile test so
there's the first interruption and now
all of a sudden it's not David and Dom
it's dom and leland against david and i
tried to just stick with it so when they
came back to me i just continued the
same point i was trying to make and of
course they were continuing efforts made
to derail why shouldn't he get credit
for that as i was saying just days after
the supposed victory and opening the
door of new relations kim jong-un went
to a potato farm instead of meeting with
trump's secretary of state showing that
there was really nothing there so my
what i'm anticipating from this summit
with putin would be that Donald Trump
will be incredibly impressed with
Putin's sense of humor much like he was
with Kim Jong Un's he's a great guy so
on and so forth I would be worried
especially after the NATO summit just
days ago where Trump started hinting at
maybe we go this thing our own way that
plays right into what Putin wants so I
wouldn't be surprised if that gets
pushed along a little bit of a way as
well Dom fair a fair critique and
something to be worried about no David I
don't think that's the case again again
with Kim jong-un he is not testing
missiles again he's not getting to that
final step where he's able to hit it
that's what's important not all the
posturing do I wish President Trump were
more buttoned up and sounded as say a
John Bolton might yes I do when it comes
to Putin so now they both latch on to
this talking point hey Kim jong-un
hasn't tested a missile in nine months
Dom does it and the host does it and
eventually I just asked them to tell me
why is that something that Trump gets
credit for and I admit I actually kind
of bungled it i I think I did not handle
this part as well I was not as
articulate as I wanted to be that's his
style
you guys David I think we all like his
style you don't like his style but the
results are there there are certainly no
results to speak of yet well done David
is that really is that really fair you
got nine months without a nuclear
weapons test you got nine months without
a missile test there's there's a new
report that there's actually an
advancement in the nuclear research
capabilities in norther clear because I
think that there's going to be
allegations here that I am unwilling to
see progress I actually was hoping for a
real victory I've been following the
North Korea crisis for more than 10
years on my program so I was I am
committed actually I believe it's one of
the main humanitarian crises that we let
me get a question in in reality though
president Trump was able to get a
nine-month moratorium on nuclear weapons
testing and on missile testing this from
a regime that President Obama said was
the single greatest threat to the United
States when he met with President Trump
how is that not an accomplishment in and
of itself regardless of the other issues
if all of a sudden the focus is who in
the past said that someone is AG just
answer that we've got to go back into
the drawing board that's exactly what
the entire Republican Party said about
question just answer the question how is
no missile testing and no nuclear
weapons testing in nine months not an
accomplishment explain what Trump did to
call it an accomplishment okay knock
yourself out I yeah I do they pretend
not to know what I'm asking and I think
it was pretty clear what I was asking
but yet I should have asked it I think
in a better way like for example France
also hasn't bombed Italy for the last
nine months does Trump get credit for
that or something something along those
lines I think it was okay but still they
of course had no answer to that
I mean hindsight's 2020 yes but I think
you still illustrated the point and I
think they were both stumped there they
just wanted to make it seem as if you
were the one who was asking a crazy
question they just can't understand what
crazy things I'm saying okay and then it
just goes sort of downhill from there
here's the rest of the interview
it comes back to again it is an
accomplishment and I'll be bipartisan it
was President Bush President Clinton all
American presidents couldn't break
through and even meet with this guy and
talk with him he was approaching the
final steps to be able to hit us he is
not a there's no American
that's that's the truth he is not he is
standing down I did that I would rather
see a harsher light this is an echo
chamber talking point that Trump was
able to achieve something by securing a
meeting North Korean leaders have been
desperate to get the recognition David
would have me residents and it was the
president was his tactics
it was the Trump tactics that got the
meeting and who knows maybe woke up Kim
jong-un to know every allottee of this
versus other American presidents all
right we move on will no evidence of
that move on real quickly to the
president's interview with CBS this
morning that aired about the hacking of
emails by the Russian government take a
listen what the president said
I think the DNC should be ashamed of
themselves for allowing themselves be
hacked they had bad defenses and they
were able to be hacked but I heard they
were trying to pack the Republicans too
but and this may be wrong but they had
much stronger defenses David is it a
fair critique that for as much as the
Democrats cry and scream about Russian
collusion and or Russian intervention in
the election it was Democrats who were
in charge of the national security
apparatus when it happened the the idea
here that if you are a victim of hacking
it's the fault of the victim when you
don't want to blame that heat that party
who did the hacking is absolutely
hilarious and anybody who doesn't see
the absurdity of that on its face it's
going to be very hard to actually engage
on the facts when it comes to that and
what the the real big news related to
this is that we now know that when
Donald Trump quote jokingly said hey if
Russia wants to hack Hillary's emails
that wouldn't be a bad thing the first
attempt to do that happen within hours
of that statement that's really the news
DOM and Leo and I would counter that we
do know from the Rosenstein report on
Friday the big news is no American
citizen committed any act of collusion
or crime and there's no evidence the
Russians were effective I don't like
what the Russians did either but they
weren't effective
and you got to knock off this witch-hunt
wait it's wait a second guys hold on
hold on a second wait wait a second a
witch-hunt that finds 32 witches already
is not exactly a witch number 2 when you
say no American citizens have been
accused of crimes Paul man afford I
think is American I know a lot of
Americans did the crime of colluding
with the Russians he's not accused of
that collusion is not burning witches
thank you very much we appreciate it
obviously a spirited discussion went on
a little bit longer than we thought it
would which is a good thing we'll see
you guys soon yeah so I was immediately
flooded with insane hate mail on
Facebook Twitter Email even Instagram a
few samples John wrote in saying I just
decided to take a google search on you
and wow what a waste the usual arrogant
condescending idiot probably successful
in your target market have a nice life
Frank Roden how does this tool even have
a radio show is your studio located on
Newbury Street thank God for Howie Carr
Ron I don't know what that the bottom
line that's think that's annex that that
is my type over there Ron wrote in if
you intended to embarrass yourself on
Fox News you did Joe after eight years
of vacillation and cowardice by Obama
and Clinton incorporated your
nonsensical hysteria over your mythical
Trump ski is laughable you are just
another mindless pole smoker hiding out
in the wannabe totalitarian one-party
city-state of Boston you are yet another
useless faux liberal air thief who has
never had a real job we have a couple
others Pat wrote in not this Pat no one
likes a smug evasive liberal dumbass and
lastly Mike saw you on Fox News today
how in the hell do you keep a show you
are a brain-dead [ __ ] you have been
following North Korea really what does
that mean thank God for you there is
lowlife trash Democrats that follow your
show you are a joke what a clown stay in
Boston great place for you millions of
us are grateful for all the amazing work
our president has done sorry piece of
garbage Hillary did not win but thank
God for our country we have a real man
for president not a pathetic joke like
you so my question is is it worth doing
this is it worth doing this or is it
just a total waste of time that's my
question to you and I look forward to
hearing from you about it one of today's
David Pakman show sponsors is world
crypto con it
a three-day event at the Aria Resort in
Las Vegas from October 31st to November
2nd
this year's theme of world crypto con is
achieving mass adoption of
cryptocurrency and blockchain technology
specifically through small medium and
enterprise business innovation you can
join over 5,000 attendees check out the
hundred and fifty plus exhibitions
stretched out over two hundred thousand
square feet of meeting space enjoy a
full schedule of speakers including many
of the biggest names in the blockchain
world and the David Pakman show audience
can get a $300 discount on tickets by
using promo code Pakman at World crypto
con-com I've put a link in the
description under the video once again
that is promo code PA que ma n at world
crypto con-com